[Music]
foreign
my name is Andy tujer and I'm a package
developer educator on the Tidy verse
team at posit
I'll be teaching a workshop at the
upcoming posit comp in Chicago called
fundamentals of package development and
I wanted to give you the top three
reasons why I think you might want to
join us at the workshop
the first is just getting started
you might have an idea for a package
already but don't really know where to
start or you might have done some
package development before but feel like
you could do some help being a bit more
efficient about it
the workshop will be an interactive and
hopefully fun run through the package
development process
We'll Be Live coding together and
building in our package from scratch and
along the way learning the basic moving
Parts in our package
the second reason is to learn good and
easy practices you'll learn the tools
and techniques that the tidyverse team
have developed and used in their
day-to-day work
these practices really smooth off the
rough edges of the package development
process and help prevent you from many
of the common pitfalls you might
encounter
they are designed to help you fall into
a pit of success instead
using these tools helps you build a
workflow that gets the esoteric details
of package structure out of the way and
helps you focus on the content
and third just to help you get better at
r you might simply be looking for that
next step in your R programming journey
and want to build some new skills
if you feel like feel like you've
plateaued and developing your R skills
learning package development can be a
great next step in moving along in a
Continuum from data analysis to building
tools for yourself and other people and
also to start to learn how and when to
apply software engineering principles to
your work
so if any of these points or all of
these points resonate with you I hope
that you'll join us at our workshop.com
see you there thanks
[Music]